SPEAKER: --to Introduce our
three distinguished speakers
today.
Stefanie Tuder is
a San Francisco
based editor who's written
for publications including
goodmorningamerica.com,
"Food Network" magazine,
"Cosmopolitan," Zagat,
and "Time Out New
York," just to name a few.
She's currently a senior
editor at Eater SF
and concentrates on Bay Area
food news and dining guides.
Before that, she was the
associate food producer
at goodmorningamerica.com and
an editor at Zagat's review
right here at Google-- and
a bunch of other really
cool things that I'm sure
she will let you know about.
She has also graduated
from the culinary arts
program at the International
Culinary Center
in New York City.
So welcome, Stefanie.
JAKE DELL: [CHEERS]
SPEAKER: Right
next to her-- woo.
JAKE DELL: I thought
we were cheering.
SPEAKER: Right next to
her-- you get that going.
Right next to her is Jake
Dell, who is the owner and vice
president of Katz's
Delicatessen,
an iconic Jewish deli
established in 1888.
He's grown up in the
restaurant industry
and officially joined
the business in late 2009
and is currently in charge
of all major operations.
So right now, he's working hard
to modernize the 130 year old
deli system and processes
while continuing
to maintain the
old-world feel and taste
for which Katz's is famous.
This is exciting.
Most recently, Jake
has expanded shipping
to include national reach.
Yes, that means us.
You can get his stuff.
It's good stuff.
And he'll open a
second location soon.
His favorite meal, in
case you're wondering,
is pastrami on rye,
which he prepares himself
with a side of latkes
and chocolate egg cream.
JAKE DELL: I go back and
forth between the egg cream
and the black cherry soda.
I don't know.
SPEAKER: OK.
STEFANIE TUDER: What's
your condiment of choice?
JAKE DELL: Mustard.
SPEAKER: Mustard.
EVAN BLOOM: There's no other.
SPEAKER: OK.
And next to him-- Evan, our very
own San Francisco Wise Sons.
So throwing elaborate
dinner parties is not
something most 12-year-olds
do, but for Evan, this
was just normal.
He started cooking
younger than most,
eschewing Kraft mac and cheese
for Thai cuisine and baked
Alaska.
His love of cooking and food
stuck with him through college.
And after studying
architecture and joining
the corporate world, he
eventually found his passion.
And it's behind the stove.
So he realized his
fondness of food
had roots in Jewish
soul cooking.
And at Wise Sons, he
recreates classic dishes
with integrity using
quality ingredients
while still hitting the
proper nostalgia that
would make your bubbie proud.
I'm going to hand
it over to Stefanie.
Thank you all for being here.
STEFANIE TUDER: Hi, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
So those are awesome
PR written intros.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
STEFANIE TUDER: To tell
you a little bit more
about these two
that wasn't in that,
Jake was supposed to be a
doctor, but pastrami called.
And it was while he was
applying to med school.
Instead, he wanted to work at
Katz's and just couldn't leave.
EVAN BLOOM: You really
disappointed your grandmother,
didn't you?
STEFANIE TUDER: Yeah.
JAKE DELL: No, no, it's a
different Jewish mother's
dream.
You just switch the dream.
STEFANIE TUDER: Fair.
And Evan has absolutely
no culinary experience
and actually started his
career as an architect.
And fun fact--
this building used
to be Gap, which is
where Evan worked.
And now, we're back
where it all started.
And then Evan, a few
years ago, decided
that he liked food instead.
Do you guys know La Cocina?
It's in the mission.
It's a nonprofit.
Yes, lots of fans.
And so Evan volunteered there
and rediscovered his love
for food and decided
he wanted to make it.
And so he started fooling
around with some recipes.
And now, they are operating
in the mission on 24th Street.
They are in the
Contemporary Jewish Museum.
And they just opened
a bagelry on Fillmore.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
So we have kind of the old
guard of Jewish cuisine
and the new guard.
Very purist-- pastrami
on rye with mustard.
And then we've got some pastrami
cheese fries to my far right.
JAKE DELL: Pastrami
cheese fries?
EVAN BLOOM: But their
sandwich kind of inspired
everything, so--
STEFANIE TUDER:
That's the truth, yes.
EVAN BLOOM: It's a nice--
JAKE DELL: Thank you.
Yeah, we try.
STEFANIE TUDER: Starting there.
So I mean, Katz's pastrami, for
those of you who haven't been,
next time you're
in New York, go.
Or ship it here.
It's really iconic.
And to walk into
something like that, how
do you tackle that and keep it
running day to day what it is?
JAKE DELL: Right.
So we go through roughly 15,000
pounds of pastrami every week.
And every pound we try and make
sure it's exactly the same.
So whether it's the first time
you came in-- or if none of you
have ever been, that
first experience
is hopefully the same as
anyone else's first experience,
whether it was 60 years
ago or a week ago.
So we cure it and smoke it
all in the old-fashioned way.
And it's just about
maintaining that food tradition
and sticking to the
classics and sticking
to-- we know what we do.
And hopefully, we try
and keep that going.
We're a little afraid
of change in some ways.
STEFANIE TUDER: Yes,
they-- for those
who haven't been-- who
has been, in the room?
A good number.
So with all of you
raised your hands,
you know about the tickets.
JAKE DELL: Wait,
Blueberry's been?
AUDIENCE: No.
STEFANIE TUDER: No.
JAKE DELL: OK, alright.
STEFANIE TUDER: For those
of you who aren't here,
there is a lovely
Jewish doodle-- poodle?
EVAN BLOOM: A Jewish Doodle.
STEFANIE TUDER: Cockapoo
in the audience.
A Jewdle is in the audience.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, kosher.
STEFANIE TUDER: Kosher Jewdle.
So you guys know about
the ticket system.
JAKE DELL: I'm not
kosher though, actually,
so no pastrami for Jewdle--
Blueberry, the Jewdle.
That's great.
STEFANIE TUDER: If you've
been to Katz's, the system
is you walk in.
You get a ticket.
Why don't you tell us
a little more about it?
JAKE DELL: Yeah, so it
is a very old system that
leads to a fair number
of problems sometimes.
STEFANIE TUDER: My dad
calls it ticket drama.
JAKE DELL: Ticket drama
is a good way to put it.
Sometimes it becomes
a battle royale.
But ticket drama is a much
nicer way to put that.
So you get your ticket, and
you go around from station
to station.
You order your food.
You sit down.
You eat.
You pay when you're done.
Seems simple enough, but people
tend to lose those tickets.
And it's just not something
you see every day,
but that's part of
the charm, right?
That's part of what
makes Katz's unique,
is that you can go and
experience these old
the ways of doing things.
And whether it's the food, or
whether it's the neon signs,
or whether it's
people yelling at you,
the ticket system,
it's the classic way to do it.
STEFANIE TUDER: You went to
Stern NYU business school.
JAKE DELL: I did.
STEFANIE TUDER: I'm sure you
learned some updated processes.
JAKE DELL: So yeah.
So I went with the intention--
I knew how we do business.
I grew up around that business
my whole life-- birthday
parties.
I had my bar mitzvah
in the store.
In fact, actually
if you look, there's
a neon sign that says "Jake's
bar mitzvah" on the side.
It's my favorite neon sign.
So I grew up-- I knew
how we did business,
but that doesn't mean that's
how the rest of the world
does business.
And so went back to
kind of learn and see
what else was out there and
read case stories about why
being in a family
business is the worst
idea in the world, and
all these horror stories,
and took what I could
from that and tried
to apply it to things you
would never see, right?
So the back to house,
boring business
of restaurant type
things, which we
both hate because
it's the boring stuff.
But you know, you need to
change those sometimes,
every once in a while.
STEFANIE TUDER:
Ordering, supply.
JAKE DELL: Yeah,
we do, in total,
30,000 pounds of
meat a week when
you add in the corn
beef, and the hot dogs,
and salamis, all those
other good stuff.
So yeah, things like that.
The ordering process
is important.
Your supply chains, if you
will-- all that fun stuff.
STEFANIE TUDER: So if that's
your least favorite part,
I would imagine interfacing
with people is among--
JAKE DELL: No, I hate people.
I'm really shy.
STEFANIE TUDER: You went
into the right business.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
No, I love talking to people.
That's what makes
it special for me
is the fact that I can go
around from table to table
and talk to customers.
STEFANIE TUDER: Who do
you see on a daily basis?
JAKE DELL: Everyone.
I get regulars from
all over the world.
But I have a couple favorite
regulars always that come in.
And usually, they're
old-timey in their ways
and like to yell at me.
So that's always fun.
But I actually--
STEFANIE TUDER:
Jews are particular.
They know what they like.
JAKE DELL: Oh, for sure.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm sure Blueberry
the Jewdle would agree--
very particular dog there.
So actually, there's one
woman that comes to mind
who's-- she's 94, 95.
And every time she comes in,
she tells me the same story.
And I know the story by heart
because she's told the story
20 times at this point.
But every time, I can't
help it because it's
such a sweet story about
how when she was a kid,
she would come with
her three sisters.
And they would spend the whole
week making these tchotchkes.
And they would sell
it on Delancey Street.
And then we use whatever
they made for the week
to buy a sandwich.
And they would split
it four ways, and that
was her weekly tradition.
And so even though her three
sisters have now passed away,
she comes back and she just
thinks of their memory.
And she inevitably cries.
And then I cry about it
because she's crying.
And then it's just
like a whole thing.
STEFANIE TUDER: I mean,
that's a lot to uphold.
Katz's is-- for you, it's
your family business.
But a lot of people consider
it theirs, I would imagine.
JAKE DELL: That's what I love.
That is 100% my favorite
part of the job,
is that for everyone who
raised their hand that they've
been before, you guys
all have your own story.
And you all have your own
history with the place.
And my story is
just one of many.
I'm lucky enough that my
story started in the womb.
And it's a web, right?
Katz's creates this
web where we're all
connected with this
food tradition that
is, in some ways,
largely disappearing.
But thanks to Evan and
other people out there,
it's coming back.
And there's this love
and just great desire
to get back to that
food tradition.
STEFANIE TUDER: Mhm.
Great intro to Evan.
Thank you.
JAKE DELL: I try.
STEFANIE TUDER: So you guys
are kind of the purists.
You are what Jews have
been eating for centuries.
Evan, tell us a little bit about
what Wise Sons does instead.
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah, whereas
Katz's is the institution,
we're the new kids on the block.
We have to balance the nostalgia
that people come in with--
and they may have gone
to their local deli.
Or a lot of our customers
grew up in New York and went
to Katz's.
And they come, and
they have expectations.
And a lot of those
expectations--
you know, part of it is
eating that sandwich.
But a lot of it is also the
story that goes along with it.
So a long time ago-- well, we
haven't been around that long.
But in our age a long
time ago, we kind of
said, all right, there are
these people that they come in.
They're going to
complain about the food.
It's not going to taste
like the sandwich they had
with Uncle Irving on Sundays.
But the fact that
they are coming in
and they're imagining--
they smell the corned beef.
And all of a sudden, they get
brought back to that time.
That brings us satisfaction.
Because we aren't a
100 year old business,
130 year old business.
STEFANIE TUDER: Can you
tell people a little bit
about your menu to everyone?
EVAN BLOOM: Sure.
So we are a Jewish deli.
We make everything from scratch.
Basically when we
started, I was in New York
and I was eating
a Katz's sandwich.
And I said, well, shit.
We don't have this
in San Francisco.
I went to school at Berkeley.
Came here, worked at
corporate for a couple years.
Hated myself.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
STEFANIE TUDER: No offense.
EVAN BLOOM: I was really unhappy
and started-- my brother was
getting an MBA at the time.
And he was like, here's
a business plan template.
Keep yourself busy.
So I'd been to New York.
I'd eaten the sandwich.
We were trying to
recreate in our backyard.
And it kind of just
started to gather steam.
And eventually, we opened.
We did a pop-up.
We based our menu
on kind of what
we call the pillars of Jewish
deli-- the pastrami sandwich,
the pickle, the matzo ball
soup, chocolate babka.
For us--
JAKE DELL: I hate
all of those things.
EVAN BLOOM: Terrible things.
I don't eat any of them.
So that's kind of--
we said, OK, we're
going to set out to make great
pastrami, great rye bread.
Because we looked around
and nobody was making it.
So we had to do it ourselves.
Keep in mind that making things
from scratch was not-- it
was not our intention.
Our intention was to serve
the best that we could,
but we couldn't find
the products here.
So we start making the pastrami,
the rye bread, the matzo ball
soup, the chocolate babka.
And we started writing
the restaurant menu
and realizing that
we wanted to put
some personal touches on it.
But at the same time, we wanted
to serve the things that were
the classic Jewish deli dishes.
So in New York, there's a
lot of the new guard as well,
but they're the new-- the
Mile End, for instance.
And they can put whatever they
want on their menu, right?
Because if you wanted to go get
a matzo brei, or a lox, eggs
and onions, or these
classic Jewish deli dishes,
you go to how ever many
different places in New York.
But here in San Francisco,
there wasn't that.
So we struck a balance.
STEFANIE TUDER: Are you throwing
shade at Sol's and places
like that?
EVAN BLOOM: San Francisco.
STEFANIE TUDER: OK.
EVAN BLOOM: Sol, great people.
They've been nothing--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
EVAN BLOOM: They're gone.
Joe was a great guy.
I mean, we--
STEFANIE TUDER: Did you
put them out of business?
EVAN BLOOM: No shade.
No, he was trying to sell
me the business for years.
No shade.
We couldn't find
what we imagined--
my nostalgia, my
partner Leo's nostalgia,
the things that were visceral.
So we put our own touches.
We have pastrami cheese
fries on the menu.
We have a burger that has
like a beet horseradish spread
and we grind pastrami
into the burger patties.
Instead of serving
bacon, we serve pastrami
that we treat like bacon.
But we also have all
the classics as well.
I'm sure at Katz's, you
can't get a vegan Reuben.
JAKE DELL: I don't even
know what that means.
EVAN BLOOM: Right?
Exactly.
We do smoked mushrooms
instead of pastrami.
So there are some
touches that are our own.
But at the end of the day--
STEFANIE TUDER: I mean,
what choices did you
have to make Jewish
deli relevant again
in San Francisco?
I mean, no one--
well, not no one.
But a lot of people
in New York aren't
begging for a vegan Reuben.
But I would bet that there
are people here who care.
And so have you run
into that a lot,
the San Francisco customer?
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah,
people come in,
and they're stoked
that they have options.
And we don't have necessarily
the built-in population
that's going to go
to the deli and get
a pastrami sandwich everyday.
When we opened Wise
Sons on 24th Street,
I lived two blocks away.
That's a neighborhood
restaurant.
It doesn't matter-- and I
think at a certain point,
Katz's is too.
It's a blue-collar
restaurant, right?
People come in.
They're not just Jews.
They're not just
looking for deli.
They may be looking for
breakfast or a hot dog
or whatever it is at
any time of the day.
And I think when we opened,
we were-- and we still are.
We want to be a neighborhood
restaurant before we're just
like this Jewish deli.
STEFANIE TUDER: So why not
go the traditional route then
if you wanted those dishes?
EVAN BLOOM: Well, I think
that's a tough question.
But I think to go the
traditional route,
it's hard to be a new
business and do that.
We don't have the
history, the roots,
that a lot of these other
old-school places have.
And again, we don't necessarily
have the community here
to support that.
It's also important to us.
We use high quality
meats and produce.
And we're in the Bay Area.
And we want to be kind of
a Jewish deli that serves
the populous of the Bay Area.
My intention was not
to open a New York
place in San Francisco.
STEFANIE TUDER: Mhm.
EVAN BLOOM: Right?
STEFANIE TUDER:
It's true, though.
The history is a
huge part of it.
I mean, Katz's has almost
taken on a life of its own
at this point.
Not to discredit what
you do because it's
so important to keep
it super high level,
but how much do you think
is the history of it
and how much do you think
is what you guys are
doing to move it forward?
JAKE DELL: I would say
that's the majority of it.
I mean, the people don't want
me to make a vegan Reuben.
That's not what
is expected of me.
And in many ways, that's
actually very lucky
that I don't have to
have those same issues
and that I can focus just
on the core of what we do,
what we know how to
do, and not change is
amazingly lucky in some ways.
Yeah, it's got its
own set of challenges.
But in other ways,
it's a lot easier.
Stick to the classics
and give the people what
they want-- different populous.
EVAN BLOOM: Different populous.
JAKE DELL: Either way, give
the people what they want.
STEFANIE TUDER: But
either way, I mean, even
your customer base is changing.
The Lower East Side itself is--
JAKE DELL: Oh, absolutely.
STEFANIE TUDER: My mom grew up
Jewish on the Lower East Side.
And now, you can't find
many Jewish families
on the Lower East Side.
JAKE DELL: True.
Look, that's part of what
makes New York so unique and so
special in its own way, is
that it's constantly changing.
And you go one day, there's
an Indian restaurant.
And the next day,
it's an art gallery.
And the day after that,
it's a clothing store.
And you're like, what the hell?
This was a week.
But for us to be able to stay
the constant while everything
else is changing
around is so important
to me, and to my family, and
to my extended family, and any
of my customers.
And I do view it
as one big family.
It's the inner Jewish
grandmother in me
that wants to feed people.
And so I want to feed people
what the classics are--
a pastrami sandwich.
That's what I do.
STEFANIE TUDER: So
you guys have had
to make a few changes
to kind of protect that.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, of course.
Over time, there's certain
things you do have to do.
We did add a Reuben onto
the menu 40 years ago.
That was a big deal.
STEFANIE TUDER: Congratulations.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, that
was a pretty big change.
STEFANIE TUDER: I'm sure
you remember that well.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, yeah,
it was a big deal.
It was a big whole thing.
And then cheese steak like
10 years ago, that was--
AUDIENCE: Wow.
JAKE DELL: I know.
I know.
It was a big deal.
AUDIENCE: Is that kosher?
JAKE DELL: Yeah, no, not at all.
STEFANIE TUDER:
Not for Blueberry.
JAKE DELL: Sorry, Blueberry.
No food for you.
Yeah, little things
here and there--
we upgraded our cheese
cakes 15 years ago.
So--
STEFANIE TUDER: Customers
are still rocking.
They can't get used to it.
JAKE DELL: There's a couple
that are like, oh, I remember
when Drake's Cakes were here.
And I'm like, OK, but
Drake's Cakes sucked.
They were horrible.
No offense to Drake's Cakes.
Sorry.
STEFANIE TUDER: No
offense, but you suck.
JAKE DELL: No, it was just
that specific-- moving on.
STEFANIE TUDER: Also, you made
some more exciting changes
lately, like an expansion.
JAKE DELL: That is
definite more exciting.
So we are moving into a
small space in Brooklyn
just right over the bridge.
It's the Dekalb
market, which was
an old-- so I don't know if
this crowd's familiar with it.
There was the Albee Square Mall.
You maybe know that really
horrible Biz Markie song,
"Albee Square Mall."
It was about it too.
But there's a lot of
history in that space.
STEFANIE TUDER: No, I
think you should sing it.
I don't know if we know it.
JAKE DELL: I am
definitely-- I don't
know if I could do justice
to his beautiful voice.
STEFANIE TUDER: Fair.
JAKE DELL: We'll
leave it at that.
For anyone who doesn't
know who Biz Markie is,
highly recommend
you look him up.
So what were we saying?
Oh yeah, so--
STEFANIE TUDER: Expansion.
JAKE DELL: Right, expansion.
In some ways, it's actually
a traditional move for us.
It does seem like new and
changing and all that.
But we're losing touch with a
lot of our existing customer
base with the crowd that
would come in, drive in, park,
grab a sandwich, jump on
the Williamsburg Bridge,
and drive home-- that Brooklyn
crowd, that Long Island crowd,
that Queens crowd.
Because it's getting harder
and harder to park down there.
That neighborhood is crazy.
It's just chaos down there.
And so in some ways, this
is a small takeout only,
grab and go.
Park your car.
Get in.
Get a sandwich, and get going.
And so in some ways,
it's not new at all.
It's reconnecting with the old.
And in other ways,
it certainly is new.
It's a new space.
It's a new operation.
It's Brooklyn.
So yeah.
STEFANIE TUDER: When
is it supposed to open?
JAKE DELL: Fall right now
is when it's looking like.
But it's construction,
so who the hell knows.
STEFANIE TUDER: Another
big headline lately
was you sold your air rights.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
STEFANIE TUDER: Can you
tell us what that means
and what happened?
JAKE DELL: Sure,
I'll let you know
once I know what that means.
No, so essentially, we made
it so that no one can ever
build on top of us.
So it gets a little
misleading when
you say sale of air rights.
It's more like a transfer.
STEFANIE TUDER: Well,
you did make $17 million.
JAKE DELL: So says
the "New York Times."
So the idea was to preserve the
building, and at the same time,
allow us to reconnect in
Brooklyn, and at the same time,
expand our shipping
operations and really
grow it out so that
hopefully, we could
ship to all you fine folks.
STEFANIE TUDER: When
did you start shipping?
JAKE DELL: World War II.
STEFANIE TUDER: Literally.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
Our slogan is, send
a salami to your boy
in the army, which rhymes
if you say properly.
You guys, I'll let
you practice at home.
[MOCK NEW YORK ACCENT] Send a
salami to your boy in the army.
You have to say
it the right way.
But that was only
salamis, and it was only
to soldiers overseas.
And then in the early
'90s, we kind of
expanded it a little bit.
So our regulars, mostly
in Florida, who said
we really want to
some pastramis--
STEFANIE TUDER: All
those snowbirds, they
need their pastramis.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, they
really want that pastrami.
So we started wrapping it up
in the most inefficient way
you can imagine it.
It was just like
ice blocks, and just
like wrapping it and then
throwing in this big box
and hoping that it got there OK.
And then over time, we kind of--
EVAN BLOOM: They all died.
Next chapter.
JAKE DELL: Damn,
that's really dark.
Yeah, then we sort
of expanded it
and built it out a little bit.
And now, we just started
offering a two-day shipping
option as of two
days ago, I think.
And then I'm hoping,
in a couple months,
I can really drop
that shipping price
and do it at a
reasonable price, get you
some pastrami over here.
STEFANIE TUDER: So if I ordered
it, what would it look like?
JAKE DELL: Not that you can't
get pastrami over there.
But you know--
EVAN BLOOM: It's OK.
JAKE DELL: Maybe you're not
in downtown San Francisco
and you can't go to him,
so you need somebody
from pastrami from me.
That's fine.
What does it look like?
STEFANIE TUDER: Mhm, like If I
were to order it today, in two
days, what am I going to get?
JAKE DELL: Like a
pastrami sandwich.
What do you mean, what
does it look like?
STEFANIE TUDER: But It's
already on the rye bread?
JAKE DELL: No, so
it's sliced meat,
packaged bread
separate, pickles,
finishes-- all
separate-- mustard.
And just sort of heat
it up a little bit.
Slop it all together.
Or eat it cold if you're
feeling like an animal.
But I would recommend eating it.
I recommend you make a
nice, beautiful sandwich.
STEFANIE TUDER: Do you
do delivery in New York?
JAKE DELL: I do.
I do, yeah.
I cater all over the
city to different events
and parties and
things like that.
I think a bike delivery here
would be a little difficult.
I could work on it.
STEFANIE TUDER: Well,
you guys deliver.
You know how it
works here at Caviar.
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah, well, it's--
JAKE DELL: No, no, I
just meant from New York.
That would be really far.
STEFANIE TUDER: Yeah, it
would take a little while.
Have you had a lot of
success with delivery here?
EVAN BLOOM: Absolutely, yeah.
STEFANIE TUDER: How much
of your business is it?
EVAN BLOOM: About
10% of our business
is delivery in San Francisco.
A lot of people hung over
on Saturdays and Sundays
want their brunch
delivered to them.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, I
can't get out of bed.
STEFANIE TUDER:
We've all been there.
JAKE DELL: Just send
my some food immediate.
EVAN BLOOM: And San
Francisco is so big.
It's so hard to get around.
STEFANIE TUDER: Sometimes,
you can't get out of bed.
You just can't.
EVAN BLOOM: Hey, I understand.
STEFANIE TUDER: So how do you
feel about someone like Evan
coming in, and-- be honest.
JAKE DELL: Wow, that was-- you
almost caught me on that one.
I hate this guy.
I hate everything he stands for.
That's it.
I'm out of here.
STEFANIE TUDER: That's why
we put you two together.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, that's it.
Get out of here.
No, I love it.
I actually think it's
the best thing that
can happen in a deli.
And I think what he's
doing is spectacular.
Because when people start to
forget about the deli food
tradition, it hurts the
entire deli business.
What if you turned
around tomorrow,
and there were no
Chinese restaurants left?
You know what I mean?
And there's one Chinese
restaurant left.
EVAN BLOOM: It's like a
Jewish person's nightmare.
STEFANIE TUDER: Yeah.
JAKE DELL: No deli
and no Chinese food?
Oh my god.
Yeah, what do we
do on Christmas?
So I think it's great.
I think it brings it
back to top of mind.
I think it makes people
want these foods.
And maybe when you come to
New York, then you're like,
OK, I had his
crazy vegan thingy.
EVAN BLOOM: We don't
sell that much of that.
JAKE DELL: I want to see
what the original was.
And I'm happy to
be the original.
And that's great.
Like, that's who I am.
That's what I do.
And I love it.
STEFANIE TUDER: I know not
everyone feels that way, Evan.
EVAN BLOOM: About?
STEFANIE TUDER: About you guys.
JAKE DELL: About vegans?
EVAN BLOOM: Oh, yeah.
We have a ton of-- we
call them detractors.
Yeah, I mean--
JAKE DELL: Well, go
take them out right now.
STEFANIE TUDER: Have you guys
seen "Deli Man," the movie?
No.
OK, so it was a
documentary about this guy
in Houston, Ziggy.
And he has a deli, Ziggy's.
And it's very
popular down there.
And he's super traditional,
very much about not
evolving the Jewish deli.
And I know that Evan has a fun
little interaction with him.
EVAN BLOOM: So this guy
is like-- if you haven't
seen the movie, he's like
exactly what would you
expect a guy that runs
a deli to look like.
And he speaks in Yiddish.
But you know, he's
probably like 50, 45.
STEFANIE TUDER: Nothing
wrong with that.
JAKE DELL: He acts a
lot older than he is.
He's like an 80 year old man.
So anyways, we started
the pop-up news spread
that we were going to open a
restaurant in San Francisco.
And I get a one-liner
email from him.
It was like, no subject.
Hey guys, just so
you know, I might
open in San Francisco, Ziggy.
And I don't know whether it
was like meant to scare us,
or that we shouldn't be trying
to do this new school thing.
But--
STEFANIE TUDER:
And in the movie,
he explicitly talks
about how he doesn't
approve of what you're doing.
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah, I
mean-- and that's cool.
To each their own.
We're kind of used
to it, at this point.
And I mean, we own it.
STEFANIE TUDER: Yeah.
EVAN BLOOM: I mean,
I'm not Katz's.
I don't want to be Katz's.
They're awesome.
Their pastrami is
a gold standard.
But--
JAKE DELL: Thank you.
EVAN BLOOM: I don't
want to make that.
I don't want to
recreate that exactly.
I don't want to have
a ticket system.
I don't want to be
Russ & Daughters.
JAKE DELL: You definitely
don't want the ticket system.
EVAN BLOOM: There's
a lot we can learn.
There's a lot of things
that they do really well.
But you're an institution.
I'm never-- maybe in 130 years.
Real estate doesn't work like
that anymore, but you know.
We have a long way to go.
And there's no wrong way,
as far as I'm concerned,
to have a deli and to
serve a pastrami sandwich.
It's just a place for people
to come together and eat
a certain type of food.
But I don't think
the formula that
worked 30 years ago, 40
years ago, 100 years ago,
is necessarily going to work
for a new restaurant now.
JAKE DELL: Also I-- if I
may jump in real quick.
STEFANIE TUDER: Please.
JAKE DELL: With Ziggy,
he and his father
actually came-- in the
same film, he came in
and we showed him
how we pickle it
and we showed him the
back room and all that.
And we were teasing him and we
were joking with him about him
being the new kid on the block.
And my father was joking with
him and giving him a hard time.
And I'm a little surprised.
I think maybe he was just giving
you a hard time because I--
EVAN BLOOM: Totally.
JAKE DELL: I think he does
also agree that delis should--
the more, the merrier.
EVAN BLOOM: Right.
And you know, we're not opening
next door to each other.
He's in Houston.
I'm never going to
Houston, not even to visit.
Sorry if anybody's from Houston.
JAKE DELL: There's a
fake Katz's in Houston.
STEFANIE TUDER: Really?
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
EVAN BLOOM: Do you guys
have a lot of knock-offs?
JAKE DELL: He pretends he's
related to us, but he's not.
STEFANIE TUDER: I
mean, the fact is,
though, is that the
Jewish deli is dying.
And there used to be
thousands of them.
And now there's
maybe 100-- not even.
EVAN BLOOM: Well, there's like
a crazy statistic in New York.
I don't know if you--
JAKE DELL: Yeah, David--
have you read his--
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah, of course.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, I mean David
is like-- he loves to talk--
EVAN BLOOM: If you haven't
read "Save the Deli,"
it came out probably
just before we opened.
It's incredible.
This guy, David Sax,
writes about kind
of the history of deli
and where it's going,
or where it was
going five years ago.
JAKE DELL: Yeah,
he's a character.
I mean, he really
did his research.
The first chapter is him cutting
at Katz's, being a cutter,
and his experience with that.
STEFANIE TUDER: How can
you spotlight as a cutter
at Katz's?
JAKE DELL: He was horrible.
He was so bad.
I loved him, but he
was the worst cutter
I've ever seen in my life.
EVAN BLOOM: Speaking of
that, can I ask a question?
JAKE DELL: You want
to try cutting?
EVAN BLOOM: Yes.
Tuesday, I'll be there.
JAKE DELL: All
right, sounds good.
EVAN BLOOM: I can do it.
If you tip, do
you get more meat?
Is that a real thing?
JAKE DELL: That's the rumor.
STEFANIE TUDER: My
dad can confirm that.
JAKE DELL: OK, so--
EVAN BLOOM: Do you guys know?
If you haven't been
to Katz's, it's
like-- or any time
you read about it,
it's like, you have to
tip the cutter because you
get like the better quality
or more meat on your sandwich.
STEFANIE TUDER: Well, you at
least get to sample as you go.
EVAN BLOOM: People put
a lot of money in there.
JAKE DELL: They do.
They do.
So I'll say this much.
There not supposed to
necessarily do that.
STEFANIE TUDER: That's
why you keep the jars out?
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE DELL: Each
cutter's an artist.
EVAN BLOOM: It's like Subway.
JAKE DELL: Like Subway.
EVAN BLOOM: They call them
sandwich artists at Subway.
I'm just saying.
JAKE DELL: Aw, daggers.
Daggers.
EVAN BLOOM: Come on.
I had to get one in.
JAKE DELL: That pastrami that
they make, have you tried that?
EVAN BLOOM: No.
JAKE DELL: Oh, I did.
I had to try it.
It was like, aw, man.
No knock on-- actually,
no, knock on Subway.
That was horrible.
What were we saying?
STEFANIE TUDER: The tipping.
EVAN BLOOM: That's one thing
we can agree on, right,
is that there are so
many sandwich places now
that are serving such like--
JAKE DELL: Garbage.
EVAN BLOOM: Such garbage,
and meat that's got--
JAKE DELL: Boar's Head, ugh.
EVAN BLOOM: --all the stuff
pumped into it, and you know.
It's pretty brutal.
JAKE DELL: I think
it's something
that Blueberry would hate.
EVAN BLOOM: Yes.
JAKE DELL: I think we
could agree on that.
STEFANIE TUDER: The
discerning dog over there.
So what do you
think you're going
to do to keep Katz's around
for another 130 years?
JAKE DELL: Well, if I'm
alive for the 130 years,
then god bless medical
technology, first of all.
STEFANIE TUDER: You never know.
JAKE DELL: And then
we'll actually have proof
that pastrami keeps
you alive for longer,
so well, I'll be golden.
What do I need to do to keep it?
I think just stick
to the classics.
And I've touched on
this, and I might
sound like a broken record.
But I think part of
it is-- it's the food.
It's the classics.
It's what we're known for.
It's hopefully the--
you said gold standard,
and I appreciate that-- that's
what I'm going for, right,
to be the best pastrami
sandwich you've ever
had in your life every
time you come in.
And it's also the
nostalgia aspect.
It's that sight-- you come in.
It's the neon signs around.
It's the ticket signs.
It's the guys
behind the counter.
It's the smells of,
well, mostly garlic,
but-- and then just the noises.
And then on top of nostalgia,
there's just the atmosphere.
And I think when you
take those, if you
want to call it the holy
trinity or some sort of other--
I don't know.
We could come up with some
stupid, deli-related name.
STEFANIE TUDER:
We'll brainstrom.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
I think as long as
you stick to that,
and we stick to who we are
and focus on making sure
that customers are
happy when they leave,
hopefully we'll be
around for 130 years.
And I don't know
what more I can do.
STEFANIE TUDER: Which is
funny, because I mean,
consistency is certainly
what every restaurant
needs focus on.
But you almost have the opposite
task of innovating and--
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah, I
mean, for us, it's
important keep things
fresh and to continue
to make people excited to come
in and eat what we're serving.
But at the end of the
day, 60% of what we serve
is a pastrami sandwich.
And at the bagel shop,
everybody wants smoked salmon.
People still come in
mostly for the classics.
It's maybe the
locals, the neighbors,
that want something different
every time they come in.
But we want to build
what you have, right?
For instance, I got
an e-mail this morning
from somebody who we cater
their son's bris five weeks ago.
And we got a thank you
note from him today
this morning with a
picture of his son.
It's like, he's a bit
fatter now but we just
wanted to say thank you so much.
JAKE DELL: I thought you
get a note from the son.
EVAN BLOOM: From the son.
JAKE DELL: That's impressive.
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah, yeah.
And you know, and we
can't wait for you
to cater his bar mitzvah.
JAKE DELL: Nice.
EVAN BLOOM: And that is exactly
what we're trying to cultivate.
I have memories as a child
going to a specific deli,
and that's forever going
to be my first impression
of Jewish deli food.
And we want to cultivate that
with families in San Francisco,
in the mission, in our
24th Street restaurant.
We're already seeing kids
that came in in their parents'
arms five years ago
are now coming in,
and they're five years old.
Surprise.
But we're starting fresh.
So we have to
continue to really try
to cultivate that community
feeling and spirit
and create our own nostalgia
while trying not to be
stuck too much in the past.
I think there's a balance.
We also need to buy
our real estate.
STEFANIE TUDER: Welcome
to San Francisco.
Cool.
Well, love to open
it up to questions
if anyone in the audience has.
JAKE DELL: This is
the way more fun part.
AUDIENCE: Evan, you
might know this.
But just down the
street, there's
this place called Eatsa,
which is where you
go order your food off an iPad.
They put your food in a box.
And there's no
human interaction.
So there are these
people cooking
food behind a wall of glass
boxes, and then you pick it up.
Given that--
JAKE DELL: I've seen
a bunch of places
like that too in New York.
AUDIENCE: In New York?
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Really?
EVAN BLOOM: Automats, yeah.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
EVAN BLOOM: Coming back.
AUDIENCE: So do you guys
think that's going to work?
Because they feel like what
makes your places so special
is the tradition, the
history, the people.
Is there a future for that?
EVAN BLOOM: That's a question.
I mean, sadly, I
think it will work.
I mean, probably
everybody-- I do it.
Like, how many times have you
gone on Caviar or UberEATS,
or you get food delivered
by somebody in a brown bag.
They give it to you.
And you say, thank
you, and you eat it.
You don't even have
to leave your house.
I think it's becoming
more of the norm.
It works for certain
types of food.
And I think it's
great for sustenance.
And I really need a salad,
and I need it quick.
And that's why you go to Eatsa.
And you know, I don't
want to talk to anybody.
But there's certainly
an element of sadness.
But that would never work
with something that we did,
because you know--
JAKE DELL: It fills
a certain role.
I agree 100%.
I think it will be
successful because there
is a certain need for that.
But it will never fill the role
of a full service restaurant
and human interaction.
EVAN BLOOM: Exactly.
There is a place for
it as long as people
don't want that interaction.
And a lot of times,
people don't.
JAKE DELL: [LAUGHS].
EVAN BLOOM: No, that's true.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
EVAN BLOOM: I mean, we're all
glued to our phones all day.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, it's true.
It's a miracle we're here
talking to you guys right now.
Actually, certain people
are live streaming it.
They're probably just at
home thinking the same thing.
Like, oh man.
Now that you've said that, I
don't want to talk to anyone.
EVAN BLOOM: They've
got pastrami delivered.
AUDIENCE: Jake, just
you talked a little bit
earlier about the ticket drama.
I would love to
hear a funny story
from the last month or two.
But I also would love to
hear about the genesis
of the commercial
for Samsung Pay.
Because to me, I
thought that was
one of the funniest
commercials I've ever
seen-- Hannibal Buress
walking into Katz's Deli
and using Samsung Pay because
it works everywhere, even
at Katz's Deli.
JAKE DELL: Yeah,
so I have a feeling
like you had a bit of drama
in the past with the ticket
system.
So I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: I'm like a soup nazi.
I walk in, order,
step to the left.
JAKE DELL: Oh, OK, good.
AUDIENCE: I knew
exactly what to do.
STEFANIE TUDER:
You have it down.
JAKE DELL: So you're a pro, OK.
Well, I appreciate that.
Thank you.
So a good story--
I mean, oh my god.
It just usually ends in
someone threatening--
STEFANIE TUDER: How often
do you invoke your $50?
JAKE DELL: I don't.
OK, so I threaten
people with the $50
if you've lost a ticket.
Generally, I try not to
enforce that because I
want to be a dick.
Sorry, can I say that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
STEFANIE TUDER: Please, yeah.
Anything goes at Google.
JAKE DELL: I'd rather not.
I'd rather you just
find the ticket
and we can move
on with our lives.
It's not that big a deal.
But every once in while,
you get people who
just want to make a whole show.
I had one lady who called
the cops on us because she
said we were harassing
her and we were falsely
imprisoning her.
And I'm like, lady,
all I'm asking
is can you just check the table?
You know what I mean?
It's not that big a deal.
So it can turn into
a drama sometimes.
Again, that's a nice
way to put it, right?
The Samsung Pay commercial
was very interesting.
I got a call from Samsung
in the middle of December,
which is our busiest time.
And he said, we want
to come in and we want
to film a very large shoot.
And I said, um, no.
That's not going to happen.
It's too busy.
And they said, OK.
We'll make it work, you know?
And I said, well, if
you want to pay, sure.
Yeah, no problem.
That was all their idea,
all their planning.
All my guys are in the shoot--
except for there's one actor.
If you look closely,
there's a gentleman
who was the lawyer on
"The Wire," if you've ever
watched that show.
Remember-- yeah.
That's supposed to be me.
STEFANIE TUDER: Why
weren't you in it?
JAKE DELL: I don't know.
I wanted my guys to be in it.
And I figured like,
I didn't want to--
STEFANIE TUDER: [INAUDIBLE].
JAKE DELL: Because
I do-- well, yeah.
I'll do other shows
or things like that.
I was like, let's let--
we'll let them do it and have
some fun with it and really
make it a hell of a experience.
And so the big guy,
that's one of my cutters.
He's a character, for sure.
All the guys are characters.
And so it was a fun shoot.
It was a two day shoot.
Each day was 9 hours.
And we were open to the
public while it happened.
And it was interesting,
to say the least.
But it worked out great.
And I see it all over the place.
It's fantastic, yeah.
Can't complain.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask
you about the difference
between the two
Wise Sons locations.
The museum is, I would
say, fairly traditional.
You don't have all the
same things on the menu,
I don't think.
Can you discuss why or if
that's always the plan?
EVAN BLOOM: Well,
our museum location
is-- it's more of
a sandwich shop.
We're open from 11:00
to 2:00 every day.
You come in.
You get your sandwich,
your salad, or your soup,
and you go.
So part of the reason is because
we don't have a hotline there.
Well, we have a kitchen.
We don't have like deep
fryers and griddles
and stuff to do more.
And also, the museum has hours
that they enforce with us.
We can't open until
11:00, so there's
no reason to do
eggs and breakfast
and that kind of thing.
And then of course, it's the
Contemporary Jewish Museum.
You can imagine that
most of the customers
there are coming
for their pastrami
and their chopped liver.
And then yeah, 24
Street's obviously
got a much bigger menu,
much fuller kitchen.
AUDIENCE: Well, speaking
of a second shop, Evan,
do you have any advice for
Jake on opening up a satellite,
opening up a second shop?
EVAN BLOOM: Don't do it.
No, I mean, like you
said, keep it simple.
You guys have been
doing the same thing.
And you've been doing it the
same way for a very long time.
So I'd say just make
sure that you set up
the systems ahead of
time so things are as
simple as they possibly can be.
The biggest-- we have
three places in the city.
And getting from place to
place and getting product,
I can imagine-- you
guys already do that.
But having the line set
up so you can actually
get things on time
that you need and not
get the wrong orders
inter-restaurant, that's
the biggest headache
we deal with.
AUDIENCE: We haven't
talked about bagels at all.
So I'd like to discuss bagels.
EVAN BLOOM: Do you
guys serve bagels?
JAKE DELL: Oh, bagels.
We do serve bagels, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And even-- oh,
so you do serve bagels.
Do you make them?
JAKE DELL: No, I
work with a bakery
that we've worked with
for a very long time,
actually, in Brooklyn.
So I don't have the
space-- I focus on what I--
EVAN BLOOM: Don't do it.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, it's a
whole different headache
when you're talking a bakery.
And he can definitely
attest to that.
AUDIENCE: New York bagels
versus San Francisco bagels--
is there controversy?
JAKE DELL: I haven't tried
San Francisco bagels,
but I imagine they're horrible.
EVAN BLOOM: They're terrible.
I'd say the biggest
thing that gets
me, just quickly, is I hate it
when people call us a New York
deli.
I hate when people
compare us to New York.
We're not New York.
We're not trying to
be a New York deli.
We're trying to serve
Jewish deli food, which yes,
has origins in New York, but
we don't want to be that.
And I also find it hard when
people say, oh well, it's
a San Francisco bagel.
Because that's basically
just people saying it's
not a New York bagel.
We just try to
make a good bagel.
That's all it is.
STEFANIE TUDER: It's different.
It's good, but it's
just different.
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah, because
the streets don't--
JAKE DELL: No, lay in more.
I know you're holding
back right there.
You were [INAUDIBLE]
STEFANIE TUDER: No, I'm not.
I love their bagel.
I've written about my
love for their bagel.
And it's just like you
encounter all the time.
It's just not the food of
my youth and my memories,
but that doesn't
mean it's not great.
EVAN BLOOM: Right.
AUDIENCE: In a city with
relatively few Jews such as San
Francisco-- you don't
have that problem there.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, we have
a couple Jews in New York.
STEFANIE TUDER: This is
that entire [INAUDIBLE].
JAKE DELL: Jewgle, right here.
AUDIENCE: Wise Sons, it might
be the only time in a week,
or two weeks, or a
month that somebody
interacts with Jewish culture
or Jewish American culture.
And so my question is, do you
ever feel a certain pressure
to represent Judaism or Jews in
America or anything like that?
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah, absolutely.
I would say about 40% of
our customers are Jewish.
But we looked at it.
People said, why San Francisco?
There's not a lot of Jews.
Well, there are a
fair amount of Jews.
They're just not
the ones that are
going to synagogue every
week or celebrating Shabbat
every Friday.
But they're out there.
You wouldn't
believe-- they're OK.
On Yom Kippur when people are
supposed to-- Jews are fasting,
we get Jews that come in to
eat because they're just like,
it's a Jewish holiday.
I should do something Jewish.
People's parents come into town.
And they're like, oh,
I have to take them
to the Jewish restaurant to
make good on that, you know?
And that's great.
I love being that.
Because that's what I
wanted before we opened.
I have a strong Jewish identity.
I went to Jewish summer camp.
I was never religious.
So it was always cultural.
It was always about
the food for me.
So we want to give
those people a place
to come in and eat and hang out.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys get the
sense that outside of New York,
there's probably a market for
one great deli in every city?
So I'm from LA, Brent's
Deli, and then everything
else for me.
EVAN BLOOM: [INAUDIBLE].
STEFANIE TUDER:
[INAUDIBLE] I don't now.
AUDIENCE: No, Brent's.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, you have
that in a couple of places.
If you're saying, like
anyone from Chicago
will immediately
say Manny's right?
Or if you're in Michigan,
they're like, oh,
got to go to Zimmerman's, right?
In some ways, people have that.
People have their favorites.
And I don't know that you can
necessarily compare or compete
with people's first love.
So you know.
EVAN BLOOM: There's
always room for good food.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, exactly.
EVAN BLOOM: Like a Jewish
deli, at the end of the day,
we're just another-- well,
it's pretty American.
But we're another ethnic food.
It's like saying, I want
to go to Chinese food.
I want to go to get sushi.
I want to get a
pastrami sandwich.
So there's room.
I think what's
interesting is all
of these bigger industrial
cities that have institutions,
like you said.
And I feel like that's a lot
harder to build these days.
But it's definitely
something we think about.
AUDIENCE: Are you hoping to
be that for San Francisco?
EVAN BLOOM: Yes, absolutely.
I think our Instagram handle
is San Francisco's Jewish Deli.
We want to be-- I mean, again,
we don't want to be Katz's.
But when people
think of pastrami
in San Francisco
or Jewish deli, we
want to be on people's tongues.
That's our goal.
SPEAKER: We have
time for one more.
JAKE DELL: Tongues, I like that.
EVAN BLOOM: Tongues.
AUDIENCE: Congrats out on
opening the Fillmore store.
EVAN BLOOM: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In general, I wanted
to hear how it's going.
I'm super excited about
the Fillmore restaurant
and neighborhood growing,
right, to sort of
see you guys as one of
the new anchors of that.
And so thoughts, comments?
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah.
So for those of you
that don't know,
we opened a commissary
and a small bagel shop
on Fillmore and Geary, across
from State Bird Provisions
if any of you guys
have been there.
The Fillmore was the Jewish
neighborhood in San Francisco
probably until like 1940.
So there's a lot
of history there.
It's really cool to be
opening a Jewish restaurant
in that neighborhood.
You know, I'm not going to lie.
Weekdays are tough over there.
There's a good amount
of foot traffic,
but it's not like
being in, I think,
some other neighborhoods
in San Francisco.
I think people ask
why the Filmore?
It's central location.
There's a lot of people
coming through there.
Weekends are insane because
people are nearby in their home
and they come through.
But also, it's
continuing to grow.
For those of you--
STEFANIE TUDER:
Where's the next one?
EVAN BLOOM: What was that?
STEFANIE TUDER:
Where's the next one?
EVAN BLOOM: I don't know.
I mean, which next one?
STEFANIE TUDER: That's
a bigger question.
EVAN BLOOM: But if you've
been to like Divisadero
and seen how Divisadero
and the corridor's
beginning to really--
like new restaurants
are opening every week.
I think Fillmore is probably
like five to eight years
behind that.
AUDIENCE: What's maybe
going to help that location?
Like, what's the best in
terms of bringing people
in on an ongoing basis?
EVAN BLOOM: Come by during the
week and order catering, guys.
Order catering.
STEFANIE TUDER:
Guys, the takeaways
you need from this is
Katz's ships nationwide
and Wise Sons is on Caviar.
JAKE DELL: There you go.
EVAN BLOOM: Come by.
Tell your friends.
JAKE DELL: That's
the CliffsNotes.
EVAN BLOOM: Put it on Twitter.
Put it on Instagram.
AUDIENCE: It seems like we
needs kids with brisses and bar
mitzvahs as well.
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah,
that'll work, too.
JAKE DELL: Or adults, but
that's a little [INAUDIBLE].
EVAN BLOOM: But
also, guys, we're
at ferry building every
Tuesday, Thursday and Saturday.
Come by.
I'm there a lot.
Come say hi.
But just coming in.
Yeah, people are like,
what can we do for you?
Just come in and eat.
That's all.
Come in.
Eat a little bit.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, yeah.
You're so skinny.
Eat.
Yeah, you're all skin and bones.
EVAN BLOOM: I'll tell you.
I'm really excited I'm
going to New York tomorrow.
And I'm going to go
into Katz's on Tuesday
and hopefully get that
the official tour.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
EVAN BLOOM: Do I
get to stand behind
the counter-- not to cut meat.
I just want to walk back there.
JAKE DELL: That, we'll see.
EVAN BLOOM: How
many years do you
have to train to be a cutter?
JAKE DELL: So you
start on the floor.
And then you go to the
French fries and sodas.
Then you go to the grill.
Then you go to the back counter.
And then you can
become a cutter.
EVAN BLOOM: I don't
think I'm going
to be able to do that in a day.
JAKE DELL: I'll give
you a shot, though.
I'll give you a shot.
EVAN BLOOM: Sounds good.
STEFANIE TUDER: Cool.
Thank you guys so much
for being here today.
EVAN BLOOM: Yeah,
thank you, guys.
JAKE DELL: Yeah, thank you.
EVAN BLOOM: I think we'll hang
out if you guys have questions
afterwards.
JAKE DELL: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]